salut aujourd'hui c'est la 281 8e vidéo
du mental blog et c'est pas hasard si
vous êtes en train de regarder cette
vidéo à la fin de cette vidéo je donne
quelques infos pour ceux qui voudraient
me rencontrer mais pour le moment je
vous apprendre à prendre la bonne
décision en jouant votre vie à pile ou
face doit prendre une décision je met
souvent d'un tableau avec des plus et
des moins
hamada y voir plus clair et à être le
plus pragmatique possible dans ma prise
de décision mais parfois même quand on
fait ça on a quand même du mal à
déterminer quel est le meilleur choix
parce que dans la balance les deux choix
se valent
en tout cas avec toutes les informations
qu'on a à ce moment là les deux choix
sont à peu près équilibré il ya quelques
semaines voire quelques mois en
discutant avec une amie on a parlé de la
prise de décisions par pile ou face
et je vais vous révéler en quoi la
réponse de la pièce est tout à fait
juste
malgré le fait qu'elle soit lancée au
hasard faut déjà comprendre que
l'hésitation ça entraîne une doute qu'il
m'aime entraîne l'inaction l'idée donc
une fois qu'on a rationalisé sa prise de
décision mais que le choix reste
impossible d'éviter le doute pour casser
le processus cassé n'étant pas un
placement de produits à bon donc
j'enlève le commentaire oui enlève ce
commentaire là au final la bonne
décision sera celle qui nous ressemble
et qui marche avec notre conviction
intime et pour déterminer quelle est
notre conviction intime une simple pièce
peut suffire avant de lancer la pièce il
faut vraiment jouer le jeu mentalement
et se dire ok je vais faire confiance au
hasard et je vais suivre la décision de
la pièce donc si elle tombe surface jeu
je fais le choix sains et si elle tombe
sur pile je fais le choix de vous lancer
la pièce vous regardez le résultat est
donc quel choix est indiquée par la
pièce et vous devez assumer ce choix
comme un choix obligatoire comme s'il
n'y avait pas d'autres possibilités vous
suivez le jeu du pile ou face
jusque là je pense que l'explication est
clair immédiatement après ça vous
analysez de suite votre émotion brute
si vous avez une simple amertume ou
envie de relancer la pièce ou juste un
pincement au coeur
ça veut dire que ce choix là ne
correspond pas à votre conviction intime
et que votre vraie conviction profonde
se porte donc sur l'autre choix et si au
contraire vous êtes raccord avec ce que
disait la pièce ça veut dire que c'est
votre conviction profonde et là vous
pouvez foncer parce que en tant que
mental où vous avez compris qu'il existe
plein d'outils pour analyser les
émotions les réactions d'une personne
quand il s'agit de faire ce travail-là
sur soi
alors là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et après en avoir fait l'expérience de
manière intensive
avec toujours une pièce dans la poche je
peux vous dire que c'est une très bonne
méthode d'auto lecture vous mentaliser
mais de manière complètement autonome
évidemment je vous conseille de passer
d'abord par la phase de faire les plus
et les moins ce que j'appelle les plus
et les moins son avantages inconvénients
de chaque choix et d'utiliser ensuite la
pièce si l'analyse de départ ne suffit
pas mais et c'est ça que j'ai découvert
en l'utilisant c'est que même pour les
petites prises de décision rapides
ça peut être très utile ça permet de
s'auto analyse et émotionnellement très
rapidement il suffit juste de se mettre
en condition de se dire je joue le jeu
comme si je devais absolument suivre le
résultat de la pièce après j'imagine que
certains d'entre vous ont d'autres
m'étonne pour ça et je serai ravi de les
découvrir dans les commentaires
aussi bien pour la préparation d'une
prise de décision que pour l'analyse
émotionnel fasse un choix si vous avez
vos propres trucs vos propres astuces
vous pouvez les partager avec nous ce
sera bénéfique à l'ensemble de la team
de connaître plusieurs techniques
personnel j'espère que cette vidéo vous
sera utile pensez à laisser un petit
pouce en l'air il n'y a pas besoin de le
jouer à pile ou face celui ci est à vous
abonner à la chaîne puisque le mental
cox est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 11 heures
ciao
et vous êtes encore là c'est génial
mercredi dernier lors du mythe objet a
annoncé une petite exclu dont j'ai
commencé aussi à parler hier matin sur
les réseaux sociaux et que je veux vous
partager ici avec une petite annonce
comme vous le savez je prends toujours
le temps de vous rencontrer à la fin des
spectacles c'est un super moment pour
moi aussi c'est très agréable
donc je joue durant une heure et demie
en général on repasse une heure et demi
ensemble derrière le seul moyen de
connaître à l'avancé toutes les dates de
tournée c'est d'aller sur mon site
www.ma bien à l'écart point fr vous avez
dans toutes les vidéos depuis le début
de l'année le lien dans la description
donc j'ai passé dans tous ces endroits
mais ne vous inquiétez pas régulièrement
je rajoute d'autres dates d'autres
villes suivantes comment la tournée
s'organise l'exclu sais que je vais
faire une date à paris de mon spectacle
actuel fabien olicard vous mentalise une
un ami qui s'appelle gérald hareng vous
savez c'est celui qui faisait les voix
des minikeums qu'on était tout petit il
ouvre un nouveau lieu à paris m'a
demandé si je voulais bien venir jouer
mon spectacle je lui ai dit oui est-ce
qu'on se verra ensemble à la fin je vous
dis oui c'est le 17 décembre joue mais
les infos dans la description mais
attention au moment où je vous parle il
reste déjà plus que 79 places du moins
il reste et ça hier soir au moment où
j'ai eu générale de téléphone alors je
vais pas vous faire le coup de à
dépêchez-vous tout ça tout ça en mode en
mode techniques marketing vous faites
comme vous voulez mais comme on m'a
reproché pour le meet up ne pas avoir
prévenu à l'avancé quand 45 minutes le
meet up était complet ce coup ci
voilà je vous le dirai 79 places n'est
pas un immense cube c'est un bateau
péniche théâtre
en tout cas j'ai hâte de vous voir à
paris ou en tournée passer un bon
week-end à demain ciao